エビフィレオ依存症だから
もう見ない公衆トイレを使ってる時に隣の
人の足を見たくないから今では相槌を打た
ずに会話できないからうーん
うっつありか一刻も早くハンターハンター
の続きが読みたいから未だに大吉を引いた
ことがないから今度こそ永住権が出るよう
な気がするか
今回いけると思う北朝鮮がガチで攻めてき
た時横浜のガンダムが稼働して反撃する
飲みたいか帰国したら自分の失敗を外人
カードでごまかせなくなるせっかく覚えた
fax の使い方忘れてしまったら
もったいないかチップという概念をを
忘れかけてるからでも金額これだから自由
が強いから今出たらそもそも再入国できる
かわかんないか朝のコーヒーを買うときに
ついでにピザまも買いたいから
合わないのもわかってます銭安の中で給料
を取るでもらったか一度も日本に来たこと
がないう藪が日本のことの語る飲みたく
ないからそういう受精でキュレーション
ヘアピン座るディション走破じゃなくて畳
肌から留学時代に結んだ eu の契約が
まだ終わってないかずっと話していない
ためアメリカに変えて高校時代の友達と
再会しても話が大と思えないとめっちゃ
久しぶり中国どうだったん楽しかったよ
最近納豆の良さがやっとわかった自分の
サイバーパンク東京の偽造写真が生み出す
いい音が必要だ信号が青になるまで待た
なきゃいけないという上司気に切り替わっ
てるか右家ってなんだよ赤だぞ友達と一緒
にお風呂に入るのが好きだからアメリカに
帰ったら少しずつヒップスターになるん
じゃないかなって恐れてるから少子高齢化
を防ぐための義務を果たした
2回も熱意にスマホ見ないで自分の住所が
描けるようになった四季を感じたいから
今度の子供給付金を使って入らない
macbook pro を買いたいから
今では寒いのて in みんね how
樹齢丸って聞かれたら狼狽してしまいそう
だおえっぷらむぺーカオス毎週教会に行か
なくても宗教のいいところを享受したから
他人からプレゼントをもらうのが好きだか
ヒートテックがないと冬を乗り切る自信が
ないから
普通のタイツと変わらないということ
ちょっと話すだけでチヤホヤされなくなっ
たら精神が壊れてしまいそうだん
me